you've uh looked at the brains of um
or information coming from the brain of
some of the people
that have had ufo encounters what's
common about the brain of people who
encounter ufos
so the the study started with a group of
let's say a cohort of individuals that
were brought to me
and their mris
uh to ask about the damage that had been
seen in these individuals it turns out
that the majority of those patients
ended up being as far as we can tell
havana syndrome and so
for me at least this you know that part
of the story
ends in terms of the injury it's likely
almost all havana syndrome that's
somebody else's problem now that's not
my problem
um
but when we were looking at the brains
of these individuals we noticed
something right in the center of the
basal ganglia
in many of these individuals that at
first we thought was damage it was
basically an enriched patch
of mri dense
uh neurons that we thought was damage
and but then it was showing up in
everybody and then we looked and said no
it's actually not
the other readings on these mris show
that actually that's living tissue
um that's actually the head of the
caudate and the potamen
um and at the time and i remember even
asking a good friend of mine uh at
stanford who is a psychiatrist what does
the basal ganglia do he said oh the
basal ganglia is just about
movement and nerve and motor control
i said well that's odd because
uh you know these other papers that we
were reading at the time started to
suggest that it was involved
with
uh higher intelligence and is actually
downstream of the executive function
uh and involved with
intuition
and planning and then if you think about
it
if you're going to have motor control
which is centralized in one place
motor control requires knowledge of the
environment
you know you you don't want to move
something in and hit the table
or if you're walking across a room you
want to
be
aware and cognizant of what you might
bump into
so
obviously
all of that planning
is
requires access to all the senses
it requires access to your desires
memory knowledge of where and what you
want and desire to walk near or by like
i use the example of you're at a party
you want to avoid that person you like
that person the waiter is about to drop
something
all without thinking
you maneuver
so that actually all that planning is
done in the basal ganglia um
and it's actually now called the brain
within the brain
it's a it's a goal processing system
subservient to executive function
so
what we think we found there was
not something which allows people to
talk to ufos i mean i think the ufo
community
uh took it a step too far
what i think we found was a form of
higher
functioning and processing
so what we then looked at and this was
the most fascinating part of it we
looked then at individuals in the
families of those
uh let's say the index case individuals
and we found that it was actually in
families
and more so
this is the most fascinating part we've
probably looked now at about 200
just random cases that you can download
off of databases online
you don't see this
higher connectivity
you only find it in what kit green would
have called or has called higher
functioning individuals people who are
uh
i mean he he called them savants i i
don't have the means to
uh we haven't done the testing but it
turns out my family has it right we we
found it in
and me my brother my sister my mother we
found it as well in other individuals
husband and wife pairs
so
statistically if you had a group of 20
individuals and you found two husband
wife pairs both of whom had it and yet
it's only found at about we think one in
200 or 300 individuals the fact that two
individuals came together
two sets of individuals came together
both of whom had it implied either a
restricted breeding group
or
attraction
the reason why
it seems to be
in let's say so-called
experiencers or people who claim
if if intuition is the ability to see
something that other people don't i
don't mean that in a
paranormal sense
but being able to see something that's
in front of you that other people might
just dismiss
well maybe that's a function of a higher
kind of intelligence to say well
i i'm not looking at
an artifact
i'm not looking at something that i
should just ignore i'm seeing something
and i recognize it for not what it is
but that it is something different than
is normally found in my environment
yeah you know i have a little bit of
that
i i seem to uh see the magic in a lot of
moments like i have a deep uh it's
obviously not obviously but it seems to
be
chemical in nature
that
i just
i'm excited about life i i love
life i love like stupid things it feels
like i'm high a lot
unlike mushrooms or something like that
where you'd really appreciate that so
you're able i'm able to detect something
about the environment
that uh maybe others don't i don't know
but like i seem to be over the top
grateful to be alive on a lot of first a
lot of stupid reasons and that's in
there somewhere i mean it's kind of
interesting because um
it really is true that
our brains the way we're brought up but
also the genetics
enables us to see certain slices of the
world and
um
some people are probably more receptive
to
anomalous information
they see the
they see the magic the possibility in
the novel thing
right as opposed to kind of
finding the pattern of the common of the
regular some people are more wait a
minute this is kind of weird i mean a
lot of those people probably become
scientists too like
huh
like
there's this pattern happening over and
over and over and then something weird
just happened and then you get
excited by that weirdness and start to
pull the string
and discover what is at the core of that
weirdness and perhaps
is that
you know maybe by way of question
how does the human perception system
deal with anomalous information do you
think well it first tries to classify it
and get it out of the way if it's not
food if it's not sex
right if it's not
uh in the way of my desires
or if it is in the way of my desires
then
you focus on it
and so the i think the question is how
much spare processing power how much cpu
cycles do we spend on things that are
not those core
desires
you